interesting story about uber there's a
result report in The Consumerist which
explains that uber continues to track
the location of riders that means you if
you're using uber for five minutes after
your ride ends this is an update that
uber made to the way that it tracks
users and to do this they actually asked
customers to allow the app on your
either iPhone or Android phone to access
your location even when you're not
actively using the app and we actually
have a screenshot of the message that
many users received which we have up on
the screen for you now you can decline
this and that will force you to have to
manually enter your location on uber but
most people don't decline most people
accept so the question is why does uber
say that they are doing this well they
say quote we do this to improve pickups
drop-offs customer service and to
enhance safety now many people are
seeing that and they're saying well wait
a second why does tracking me after five
minutes after my ride ends help to
improve any of that stuff and the
problem that uber claims to be
addressing is that if you have location
turned off or at your quote you close
out the app for example after requesting
a ride from uber you might physically
change location but that won't be
reflected on the drivers map in terms of
where you're waiting for your ride so
that's a understandable problem that
most Oberer users riders probably have
experienced but for five minutes after
you've left the vehicle this is making
those who are sort of less willing to
accept this type of tracking very very
concerned because why would you need to
know where the riders are after they've
left the car yeah I think most people
get that notification and think well of
course uber has to know where I am how
else am I gonna get picked up yeah but
for five minutes after I mean what is
the cutoff point even that long after
well there's been a counter argument
made by fortune coms
Jeff Roberts who said any user
uncomfortable with ubers changes can
simply deny location access to the
company in their phone settings
then type in the address where you want
to be picked up manually my verdict on
this is number one I don't really care
about this I know how to opt-out I know
how to close my app right when I get out
of an uber and I take uber and lyft very
very and frequently the the broader
question for me is whether or not you
believe that this particular thing is a
big issue
uber tracking you for five minutes these
types of questions as technology is more
integrated and inseparable from our
lives are going to be more and more
common every once in a while I'll meet
someone now Pat who says you know I
don't have a mobile phone I don't use
technology some of them have internet
some of them I've actually met people
who don't even use the Internet they say
I don't email I just don't do anything
like that and right now it's sort of a
curiosity it's interesting you can by
and large still live day to day in 15
years will it be just as easy to be off
the modern technology grid for lack of a
better term I don't think so and then
these questions are gonna become far
more relevant when these are going to be
services that you can't so easily
separate yourself from yeah I think most
people who choose to live off the grid
aren't gonna be subject to these kinds
of things where the big brother is
watching you but it's certainly if the
government was to get their hands on
this kind of technology that would be a
reason for concern that's another aspect
where people are saying well if you're
being tracked for the five minutes after
the ride then all of a sudden that data
could be potentially subpoenaed by law
enforcement to see well what did you do
in the five minutes after you got out of
the car and many people rightly saying
that's not really any of the
government's business nor is it a birds
business and more of a practical concern
there on the bonus show today the last
super moon of 2016 Rises tonight will
vegan producer Pat be watching that will
be a question for the bonus show we will
find out Cuba is going to be allowing
Google to install servers and provide
faster internet access I have some
thoughts on that and some are saying
including a trumpet advisor Roger stone
that Donald Trump interviewed Mitt
Romney merely to torture him all of
those stories and more on the bonus show
and remember the indiegogo fundraiser is
on at david pakman.com slash donate
please check it out